we got this from Newsweek Donald Trump's
Secret Service agents set to testify
against him report a number of Secret
Service agents are set to testify as
part of a federal investigation into
Trump's handling of classified documents
Brett Baer said on Tuesday the grand
jury appears uh appearances are related
to special counsel Jack Smith probe into
the handling of classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago
so yes what uh for those who are just
tuning in or missed the last segment
what Charlie is saying is that actually
what is it you said Georgia Arizona
Wisconsin that's it Arizona with the
four Givens which is Iowa Ohio North
Carolina Florida which I feel
comfortable all will be in the
Republican category it's looking very
good for Donald Trump to win in 2024.
not only do we have the indictment in
New York but it looks like federally
they're gearing up for some kind of
indictment as well and that one can be
trickier for ballot access
the New York one will not prohibit from
actually becoming a candidate being a
convicted Federal felon is an open
question really yes but I thought I I
thought that wasn't the case I thought
uh the the talking point was even if he
gets charged it depends on what you're
tried with if you're tried with
Insurrection well they can't try him
with it classified doc but the
classified documents bar you from
running for office correct yes then how
could Joe Biden run again well because
they won't charge him yeah they're gonna
they've already defended what he did and
criticized what Trump is ridiculous but
the Insurrection one is interesting I
don't think they're going to charge such
a ridiculous claim but just for a
thought experiment because that's what
we're doing that's what they try to get
marginally Taylor Marjorie Taylor green
on in Georgia and Madison cawthorne
correct is because a lot of these
Southern States actually have
criminal code Provisions you can't be on
the ballot if you were charged
Insurrection it's a Civil War era yeah
exactly that's being more convicted of
of it I believe yeah that's right
convicted not charged with you're you're
you're correct so what's the what are
the chances
they try and charge Trump with the most
minor of minor j6 related quote unquote
insurrections like how they're getting
people on trespassing calling them
insurrectionists
what happens if they say misdemeanor
um um what do they call it um
like uh medicine what if they say
menacing in relation to January 6. it's
unclear legally but here's the greater
concern remember that strange argument
we had of whether or not California can
tell you you have to be on the ballot
based on your tax returns yeah right
Democrat primary States
are going to use these charges as a way
for ballot access in these states that
Trump would otherwise do very well in
like New York what do you mean how so
don't be surprised if New York you're
going to find out if the Democrat Party
wants Trump or does not want Trump to be
the nominee very soon and I think they
do not want him to be because he brings
out a different Vote or no one else can
bring out if the New York State Assembly
gathers and they say if you are charged
with a felony you're not allowed to be
on a primary ballot in the state of New
York now what would that mean now they
might lose it might be a silly argument
if they're successful
well Trump would then not be able to
even compete for the primary delegates
for the Republican nomination in the
state of New York interesting is that
just mean don't even try it means that
that he would if they did that then
whoever the second place person would be
would just be on the ballot right we're
an artist
yeah or whoever hasn't announced he
hasn't announced but he's probably going
to run but we're inspecting we're in
speculation World here yeah and I think
it's somewhat helpful because we're now
building out kind of a universe of all
the different dimensions of how they're
attacking Trump contingencies I actually
think this is really healthy it's kind
of how a war room talks in the best
possible way but I'm going to just say
it again
Arizona Georgia Wisconsin it's less
about messaging
it's less about the person it's about
the Machinery not the Dominion machines
but ballot chasing yeah or you have
early voting agree look at John
fetterman John Federman is United States
Senator
not because of his Charisma yeah I mean
and I can't say he's coming back to work
April 17th yeah the full force of John
fetterman how could anyone
watching any of this not be like double
G WTF mate yeah I think it is that in in
what world is a Democrat like I'm
totally fine with whatever it is with
John fetterman and yeah the the level of
cognitive dissonance with John Federer
and it's insane I just I just he's a
walking brain dead Frankenstein who
can't understand anything that is said
to him Libby have a little empathy for
the guy you know he look I I look I feel
bad for him I I am saddened by his story
it was his dream he wanted to make it to
the Senate he had a stroke I wouldn't
wish that on anybody what we need to do
right now is in our heart of hearts have
empathy for this man and just let him
vaguely
take him out of this stressful stressful
position and give him Comfort I would I
believe that Republicans in this country
should pledge right now one million
dollars towards the the retirement of
John fetterman to relax peacefully and
carry out his head medical treatment at
home
and then have somebody else be the
senator granted I know the reality there
is that it's his wife and so we don't
really want that either
you want to be the senator she seemed to
want that after she had that stroke and
everything my point is simply like in
all seriousness I do feel bad for the
guy because he really wanted to be a
senator and then he had a stroke and
it's got to be like that's the worst
thing in the world man I mean that's a
bummer but I don't it's insane that they
would put him in office who have voted
for him well what was really insane too
was when it turned out that he couldn't
understand anything that was said to him
and that everything needed to be on a on
a computer screen translated so that he
could read it and when we mentioned all
of us mentioned that this was perhaps
going to make being in Senate remarkably
difficult everyone accused us of uh
ableism and saying that his disability
you know was some issue ableism works if
it's like someone was born paraplegic or
something and we want a wheelchair
around to help them right not when like
a senator who has to debate make
decisions is having and his brain is a
problem like this isn't Stephen Hawking
over here you know what I mean yep but
there are people who were like I would
prefer that
and so that's why I call it cynical or
whatever I just I do not see
a mending of the bifurcated culture in
this country I think it's got to start
somewhere at the top and I last night I
was thinking like if Trump and Biden
could get together and just be like you
know what we're Americans first
high five a little bit that's all it
that it doesn't seem like much for them
but like the world will be like oh
America is the greatest I think that I
think that would never happen well you
know but I do think that you're right
that the culture is remarkably
um remarkably divided we don't watch the
same TV shows there's no common culture
that we have our religions our
Collective religions are incline there's
nothing that unites us I mean when I was
a kid we'd all watch the same TV shows
on Thursday night I could even probably
give you the lineup you know what I mean
it was like The Cosby Show and and
that's why I don't think it comes from
the topic on the radio it comes from the
bottom I do not believe what's causing
the divide in this country is leadership
I believe it is algorithms on social
media that manipulated young people
creating uh so so as I've explained
numerous times 10 year olds get on
Facebook in 2008 or whatever and are
immediately shuffled into two different
realities they are now growing up there
was never a point where someone just
like decided you know what I am a
conservative I am a liberal what was
happening was young kids were being fed
two different versions of Reality by
Facebook now they're a voting age there
is no bringing those people together
because they live in different realities
they don't even understand reality in
the same way exactly or the same
language they don't have the same goals
for a world view or anything like that
right so how do you if someone's entire
being their brain their body was built
on this country is nothing but white
supremacy and someone else is built on
America is a great freedom fighting
Nation civil rights Etc
you are not going to reverse 18 years of
mental development
yeah not overnight but but not even in a
few years
the decline in critical thinking in
education too that's an issue as well
like I'm thinking the long game if
there's a lot of people that will
mindlessly follow Donald Trump and Joe
Biden and do what they say which For
Better or Worse that's how people are
built sometimes and if if they see them
being kind to each other and promoting
like forgiveness they'll just mindlessly
do it and that's like the beginning and
then their kids will actually realize
why it's valuable and in 20 years Donald
Trump Jr will be president or something
like that like it doesn't have to be all
Donald Trump senior today right now or
nothing like it's we're kind of creating
the environment
I never saw it uh presidential Camp uh
campaign I've never seen like candidates
go at each other until 2016. I've never
seen them hate each other until 2016. it
was very out of character for the United
States you know I think you're on to
something with that too because there it
used prior to that it did seem like uh
Republicans and Democrats at least had
the same goals for the country right
you're right like blowing up kids
overseas funding the military industrial
complex
Tim on this I think that I'm not saying
that's a they had good goals but they at
least had the same goals yeah it was the
unit party yeah so two thoughts on this
because we're having a conversation of
how to heal the land that's kind of the
summary of what we just talked about
here the first is I don't think Donald
Trump caused the division he revealed it
he revealed 50 years of neoliberalism of
a fake currency and endless Global Wars
and invading the world and inviting the
world and re-domiciling American
industry overseas he just exposed it and
he did it in a very blunt sometimes
clumsy but awfully direct way who gave
the American population
a prognosis that was honest you guys got
tumors everywhere and I'm going to
remove them and then all of a sudden
he's the problem for even mentioning
that we have these tumors and yeah we
are really divided I think we've been
divided for quite some time and I think
there's a couple reasons for that
there's an interesting theory that we
can explore which is can a large
Republic sustain itself meaning is this
just inevitable when you have 330
million people and five you know almost
4 000 miles of land mass 3000 miles of
land mass is it is it just unsustainable
the founders were concerned about I
always hate that question because I love
this country and I love all of our you
love the size I love them they're like
Jefferson you want to go from Ocean to
Ocean see the shining sea right and yet
you know Jefferson being a completely
walking contradiction was the one that
wrote in the Anti-Federalist papers he
was afraid that large Republican
governments can't work and then he
bought Louisiana
so again that we're all walking
contradictions in some sense which
should give you comfort that even our
heroes were contradictions in some ways
but how do we heal a land this is really
the question of the Statesmen
it's a question of someone that is able
to identify the problem cogently and
then be able to come up with some form
of a prudent and healthy and realistic
solution and so Abraham Lincoln called
it the crisis of the house divided right
that's similar to what we're living
through now but I actually think we're
even more divided in some ways than we
even were leading into the American
Civil War at least there was a Christian
country back then now we have different
metaphysics and we have all sorts of
different types of views but we have
some things working in our favor which
is the great hope is that we can
de-escalate the national politics and go
back into hyper local community and just
say I don't like the person in Portland
I don't like the person in Wichita but
I'm not going to try to imperialize
their life
until we get to that the project is
going to fall apart absolutely I was
thinking about the word democracy and
how it comes from demos which means the
people and it's basically I hate the
word democracy yeah it allows the mob to
make decisions for the whole I'm not a
fan of democracy it's it's pretty brute
it's pretty like kind of rudimentary and
if we could evolve into like a
technocratic republic where we have
technology like apps where we can govern
ourselves locally I can hear me out of
this look and he's like hear me out
because we could always go back if the
power goes out we're still Democratic
Republic but we can upgrade and govern
locally because what you just mentioned
is local governance if we could somehow
send our tax dollars around locally
through a local app that's free software
you can watch the code nothing's
tracking it
um and if the power goes out you can
still set your representative to the to
the central location to govern the whole
from there because that's the least
worst of a bad government system but I
think we need to evolve our Republic
what I think you're hitting is
interesting in the sense that there are
different forms of government that might
be different for different people if you
leave the federal government out of this
equation people can then have a
structure that might better fit their
values the Amish are going to be a lot
different than you know the secular
nihilists in Brooklyn where the American
Republic has gone wrong is we have an
imperialist government that is invading
the communities and invading the lives
with an Ever
urgent pattern of behavior that is
telling people what to do and that is
really the incitement and then the one
symbol of that Donald Trump
is being martyred we also I got to
respond to what you were just saying
because while I do agree we shouldn't
just assume the founding fathers hit the
nail on the head perfectly in every as I
think it was the best ever but yes I
think it was the best even now the
structure and form of it without a doubt
the best and we could talk about why I'd
love to and I'll simplify it you've got
a Council of Elders Supreme Court you've
got a a group Gathering a communal
Gathering of Congress and then you have
the executive the Monarch all of these
different forms of government they had
seen they were like let's do all of them
and have them challenge each other and
create this networked style system it
was brilliant but what I'm saying is as
time changes and Technology changes
there's probably ways to improve however
my challenge to you in on the idea of
technocracy is or a technocratic
government whatever you want to call it
we look at how we created these
algorithms on YouTube with the intent of
creating more games of Game of Thrones
YouTube said 10 minute long content High
watch time that's what we want instead
of getting Game of Thrones what we got
were weird videos of Elsa being chased
by The Joker and Spider-Man with no
English because more people could watch
it if there was no language because it
crossed language barriers it had
multiple keyword generating figures in
it if we go the technocratic route the
only actual outcome is either a human
being is in control of the system that
we think is technocratic or we create a
mechanism by which the technology AIDS
us and then it runs Haywire because it's
impossible to predict
um you could put in stopped apps like
you need your face your social security
number to use the app it's public data
so you can see who's posting what and
that's only local someone would have to
have Supreme control over that system to
correct errors and maintain the system
it would be open source so the whole
Community would be policing the software
that seems like Wikipedia like a total
disaster and right what will happen is
you will then get uh 51 attack or
whatever it's going to be a network
system where Democrats are going to
register a bunch of people they're going
to say hey download this app on your
phone which will then make they're gonna
they're gonna say this is called Swing
Vote and if everyone signs up we can
control the system I'm thinking more of
something like public Square where you
can it's just resource distribution I
love Public Square yeah so like a
government app that's like open source
free software that is resource
distribution and then someone gets in
government and says that Ian Crossland
guy take him off the app no no it would
be we would have our own Local app so
like every city would have its own
version or every locality could have its
own version you have a great heart this
is never gonna happen
I love the heart that you have for
trying to build this it's just the
problem is the power of having an app
that control all will be corrupted by a
by a person
um it's all going to get correct like
the voting database has been corrupted
no I agree yeah it's just when you have
power it will corrupt absolutely as Lord
actins so we're looking for something
that can is the least corrupted of a
corruptable system like nothing's
Incorruptible right but if if the if you
think the technology will smooth out the
inherent corruption in men it does
because writing is a form of technology
and before it was just barbarism and now
we have organizations do people still
lie with their pen true people yeah
exactly I imagine it was much worse
before 3000 BC violence
we keep having less and less violence
you know yeah videos that helps you see
yourself so you can judge your own heart
video video being able to watch yourself
and see yourself speak you immediately
know what you're doing wrong
I hate watching myself that's the why
because you're seeing the faults I don't
think that's but I I would challenge Ian
because I think there's a deeper
philosophical point that I think Tim was
hovering over the reason why the
Constitution and the Declaration are
just as applicable today is because it's
built on Eternal truths things that are
always true what is what is a human
being what is our purpose here generally
are we naturally good are we naturally
bad I don't think a piece of technology
in fact I think technology amplifies the
worst aspects of human behavior here's a
couple certainly is right now here's a
couple problems that I think that piece
of tech we were just talking about won't
solve is that our Republic is had become
out of control in that there's 700
Representatives 700 people 600 people in
Congress 535 350 million so there
there's like 700 000 people are trying
to be represented by one guy totally you
can barely right you represent yourself
essentially so that's interesting I that
I don't I at first I was like get rid of
the House of Representatives and people
I know that's too extreme
um Mike Gravel who is Senator from
Alaska unfortunately it's passed because
the man's was amazing and I love them
created this idea of national initiative
creating a fourth branch of government
where we would set up a system where the
American people can pass laws into
Congress as well as the right that's a
terrible idea too well uh you it would
be like you know 50 Representatives one
from each state and they could come
together you know whenever convenient
that's why I'm not I'm not a more law
guy so but having the the uh Monopoly of
law in the hands of 700 600 people but
let me tell you how the founders thought
it would be until the 17th Amendment the
state legislatures used to pick the
Senators so that used to be your through
line 17th Amendment yeah we went people
State reps senator
now you say well the people pick the
Senators but now we know they're just
pseudo celebrities and they raise a
bunch of money and these elections have
become just corrupt you know contests
but the founders design which I would
love to repeal the 17th amendment I
think that'd be amazing agreed right is
now all of a sudden senators are
appointed the Senators would be
appointed by the state that's how it
worked until Woodrow Wilson 1917 I think
it was passed and it was way better
because then all of a sudden you're
right one senator for 800 let's say one
senator for
seven million people no no you went to
your State Rep to complain about your
Senator because they could recall the
senator a moment's notice that was the
original design and you know your state
senator because there's many more of
them and they're at the local level
precisely and these Senators at any time
could be called for hearings or called
for recall by the state legislature
you're not representing West Virginia
what are you doing you know that
actually does make a lot of sense
because we don't have a way to hold our
senator's response accountable other
than to just not vote for them
if we still had the 17th Amendment
Republicans would have 58 seats in the
U.S if we didn't have that that's what I
mean if we got rid of it let me I want
to say something as to what Ian was
bringing up with um 775 000 people per
representative so there's something I
refer to as the scaling problem that
people fans of the show have heard me
say a billion times but for the sake of
those who don't please bear with me if a
hundred celebrities were gifted a brand
new iPhone extreme and one percent of
those phones were defective that's one
celebrity going on Instagram saying my
phone's broken well no one cares they're
gonna buy that sucks for you bro like
your phone broke that happens a phone
broke I'll say they give up 100 million
phones with a one percent margin of
error now 100 now you have one million
people posting on social media about how
their phone broke and everyone's going
dude what happened all these phones are
broken same margin of failure
considering that now consider politics
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez represents 775
000 people about 24 or 20 percent of our
district are conservative these people
get zero representation but 200 and some
odd thousand people in that District can
take over whatever they wanted
the amount of police that are in New
York would not be enough no matter what
if every single conservative individual
said no taxation without representation
we are not getting represented
representation by ocasio-cortez she
rejects our values so we reject her now
you all of a sudden have two hundred
thousand people marching through the
streets of New York and the police have
no way to control that same percentage
of descent but hundreds of thousands of
people not getting any representation is
is cause for chaos and concern big time
so I'd like the idea of people
representing themselves directly I don't
like Democrat I don't like direct
democracy because the mob is dangerous
the collective is interesting the
collective can move together pretty well
if they have good organizations I don't
know I agree with that you think
collectives are are not good well I I I
I think that they collectives could be
as Madison wrote in I think the 51st or
54th uh Federalist prone to Madness I
think that's about right the couple of
times that I was involved in arts
collectives uh I wanted to tear my hair
out and run screen from the building
which eventually I did he wrote
specifically about the urban areas of
America at the time which have only gone
worse he said they have a proclivity to
the insane and a posture to the uh the
word was beautifully poetically put but
he said that they the mobs will descend
and demand Madness quickly and I think
that's true I mean for example there's a
great book by Douglas Murray called The
Madness of crowds I believe that's the
name of the title right Madness of
crowds you could fact check me on that
because there is a the collective can
make bad decisions very quickly I agree
that mobs and crowds okay crowds become
mobs mobs are dangerous but Collective
communication and like open source
database like GitHub that's a collective
movement I see so you're talking more
about a small D democratized system
where people can input data and allow
the information to win yeah look at
Wikipedia good luck ideally it's just
local the the ideally you're right but
look at Wikipedia it bends towards
tyranny it sure does I don't I don't
know about Wikipedia it's not open
source it's it's like uh I'm pretty sure
Wikipedia is open source the promise of
Wikipedia was that anyone could become
an editor and the internet will edit
itself the reality of Wikipedia is that
only people in the club become editors
and the people in charge can remove or
edit anything they want you read Tim
Poole's Wikipedia which I would not do
or Mine mine's a horror show mine's
actually not that bad okay mine's a
horror show it's like a drive-by-step
now everyone's going to go look at it
and it's terrible Kelly J Keynes she's a
you know women's rights campaigner in
the UK hers basically says that she's a
Nazi yes that's right and New Zealand
politicians believed that and advocated
for protesters to go out and protest her
let women speak event and they nearly
you know they
you guys are right Wikipedia is open
source one of the funniest things ever
was when I had a journalist asked me
questions and they were some this this
they want to do an interview with me and
I said you know please have your your
journalists do their homework on me
before coming and when they came they
asked a bunch of fake questions based on
nonsense from Wikipedia like when did
you invent the Zeppelin which is the fa
like yeah because the meme is for like
five six years Wikipedia claimed that I
built a Zeppelin and I was like I did
nothing in the sky I did not do this
thing yeah like they claimed that I
built a zeppelin drone modification for
aerial broadcasting which I never did
and then journalists would ask me about
it because it was on Wikipedia and it
was made up it was insane and you
couldn't get it removed I once went in
there and said guys I am Temple I never
did this they said you are not a
reliable source you're not a reliable
source for whether or not a zeppelin you
are not allowed to be a source for
yourself because bias so Wikipedia of
course is completely broken in that
concept now to be fair
like a year ago we did build a zeppelin
to retroactively make it true and then
they wouldn't put it back so there's a
difference between open open areas where
you can go do stuff on and open source
software code so like you might have an
open place where people can go and be
but you're patrolling it and policing it
in a way that people don't like
but I think that like so like that would
be Wikipedia for instance is a place
where people they they regret it sure
yeah so but if the code is available so
that I could spit up my own Wikipedia
tomorrow and I have my local Wikipedia
and this like yo this is what we believe
in this area man I mean this is just how
we see the world that I think is a lot
better than trying to just
Focus all the data into one big open pla
open platform
and we could maybe do the same with
government because I feel right now
Congress is Wikipedia they're they're
deciding what is getting passed into the
Senate they're deciding what's getting
said no to and it's it's too much
control of information that's an
interesting question we all agree
Congress has broken the question can be
why
and I think there's multiple answers the
17th amendment I think solves the Senate
question there's other answers I think
that are important I think campaign
Finance absolutely plays a role and I
say that as a conservative we were
talking well I think it's committed
American politics the nationalization of
politics is a big problem for us and the
example I like to give is when you'll
see a local uh someone running for
congress the federal level say I'm going
to clean this town up send me to DC and
say you got nothing to do either yeah
yeah when we send you to DC you're going
to talk about war and stuff and federal
budgets representing our district you're
not going to clean this town up you have
nothing to do the only way to clean up
the town is for them to get a bunch of
money and for them to get a bunch of
money
no but like let's say you have a
congressman or something yeah you have
to like you have to pack a bill with
pork for your District that's how you
yeah I guess that's what they do that's
what you do what is it about the
national initiative you guys were turned
off or at first were you not interested
in are you familiar I brought up earlier
Mike ravel's idea to create a fourth
branch of government well first we
already have a fourth branch of
government that's the bureaucracies and
they're unchecked unelected and they do
great damage so this would be a fifth
Branch the fourth branch is the doj IRS
EPA the permanent government someone
told me the corporate media was the
fourth Branch maybe we have six branches
seven yeah but the media is what the
fourth estate suppose it was supposed to
be keeping a check on power the fourth
Branch to give quote unquote the power
to the people would only be duplicative
of what the legislative branch and the
executive which are directly supposed to
be direct Sovereign to the people so
here's the instead of creating a fourth
branch of government where you could
pass laws why don't we restore the
promise of small our Republican
government which is say the federal
government should not be doing this and
you send it back to the States one of
the reasons why Congress is so broken is
that they meet too often
neoliberalism has empowered Washington
DC beyond our wildest imagination and
the original project and this is why I
think we're at in 2023 States created
the Federal Government the federal
government did not create the states and
we're in a place now where everybody
thinks the federal government created
the states and that is not true people
also think the federal government gave
us our rights which is also not correct
and so
I I don't want to get too far into the
example because I haven't thoroughly
read it or heard the arguments or
counterpoints but my initial reaction is
that it's a bad idea
restoring states rights and putting
power back to localities I think can
de-escalate our tension can
de-radicalize our politics can get us
back to live Live and Let Live and leave
me alone
and can hopefully restore Liberty I see
no other path to Salvation I some would
agree I somewhat disagree the challenge
I suppose is what we saw with the Civil
War when you had the attempted expansion
of slavery and you end up with Bleeding
Kansas so let's try and apply States
divisions to a modern era if we have a
people say people tell me all the time
Federalism is the answer a weaker
federal government more power to the
States and it's like okay then someone
from Texas will be in a relationship
with a woman who will get pregnant she
will get mad eight months in and say I'm
gonna flee to Colorado to terminate the
life of this baby
the guy in Texas is going to be like
that's illegal under Texas law but and
she'll say then I'll go to Colorado and
you can't stop me now you're gonna have
a question of what do either state do
Colorado will say the woman can
terminated the baby at eight and a half
months and taxes will be like that's
kidnapping and murder is Texas going to
send troops into Colorado to save the
life of this man's son because woman
wants an abortion there's also Democrats
of you that is insane that don't get an
abortion if she wants no matter what age
we're already there we're already out
there well that crisis is looming right
now that's what I'm saying but so so the
federal government being stronger and
preventing extra like
you there's there's no what I'm trying
to say is I don't see a solution let's
imagine a strong federal government
takes them in from Colorado and says you
can't kill the baby you're right Texas
resident Texas law says this this is
kidnapping and brings her back now the
left goes insane saying women are being
forced to give birth let's say the
federal government stops Texas and says
the woman is free to live where she
wants and she's getting abortion
let's say there's no federal government
you're going to get a dude let's let's
let's step outside the abortion uh
debate and let's talk about the trans
kids thing let's say it's for real in
California and and let's say a a man and
a wife of a kid she decides to the kid
is trans and takes him to California
without the the man's permission and the
federal government says we will not get
involved the question is at what point
does some father say I will not sit back
and wait for my son to be castrated and
then get a posse and bring him to
California
like the conflict will happen with
people fleeing other states in this way
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time